[Music]
foreign
here we will showcase the biggest
serpent monsters from live action movies
not including low budget entries or
dragons that are Serpentine but have
legs neither Chinese movie snakes so
let's get into it
number 10 the Borneo anacondas from hunt
for the blood orchid the Borneo
anacondas are huge snakes from Borneo a
South Eastern Asian country that consume
animals that ate the blood orchid a
flower that increases lifespans as a
result they continue to develop
throughout their lives and eventually
grow enormous in size females are much
bigger than males apart from having a
longer lifespan they also are
significantly quicker stronger and more
agile than both regular and Amazon giant
anacondas they also exhibit a high level
of animal intellect and aggressive
behavior
number nine the Basilisk from Harry
Potter Basilisk are a race of terrifying
Serpentine creatures created by the dark
Wizards a female basilisk known as The
Serpent of Slytherin was one of these
horrific monsters and acted as the
principal Nemesis in Harry Potter and
the Chamber of Secrets basilisks are
always vicious nasty and bloodthirsty
monsters that also petify you just by
looking at you or just by having a
momentary eye contact The Serpent of
Slytherin was a very old basilisk and
was under the control of the noseless
Dark Lord Voldemort number 8 the giant
anaconda from Snake Eyes in the movie
Snake Eyes GI Joe Origins there is a
deadly process in which candidates
training to be accepted into the ninja
Clan called the arashikage must go
through and this stage is to survive an
encounter with three giant anacondas
hiding within Caverns beneath the Clan's
home these giant anacondas are trained
to sense mistrust or dark secrets within
candidates and these snakes are huge in
size capable of swallowing a manhole in
as well as being very fast and agile
number seven the giant Adder from King
Arthur in the movie Legend of the sword
King Arthur had been captured and nearly
executed by his enemies but then there
was a small snake that assisted him only
for its head to be cut off by King
worgen Arthur's main rival with a bit of
conjuring a dark Conjuring dark magic a
gigantic 100 feet of 30 meters long
Adder smashes through the doors and
walls of the castle to save Arthur the
snake resembles a cottonmouth or a Viper
oh yeah like a sudden adder with two
huge sword-like fangs
number six a serpent called number seven
from raised by wolves in the hit series
there are skeletons of quite a few
number of giant serpents on a planet
called Kepler-22b a place chosen by
humans and also androids for human
Colony after a mass extinction due to
war on Earth number seven is a serpent
that was born from a killer Android
called Mother after its birth it
demonstrated flying capabilities and
grew immensely in a matter of hours
after feeding on mother although it
could be an apex Carnival it is seen
eating pumpkins which raises the
question of its habit and whether it was
a seed creature from ancient humans on
the planet number 5 the giant boa from
King Kong 1976. the giant boa is a
gigantic snake that appears in the 1976
film King Kong as one of the apex
predators endemic to Skull Island the
gigantic boa is King Kong's second
encounter with a snake monster the first
being the sea serpent the big sea
serpent from King Kong escapes and also
the serpentine elas
in the original 1933 picture may have
also inspired a huge boa anyway this boa
was slow but deadly as an ambush
predator
number four the fire snakes from gods of
Egypt these fire breathing draconic
Cobras were featured in Gods of Egypt as
Mounds for two women warriors called
astare and anad these serpents seem to
be cobras in basic design but gigantic
and size and armored with one snake
having black scales and the other having
white ones the mechanics Behind These
cobras fire breaths might be modeled
after the process of dragon fire breaths
from the movie Reign of Fire whereby two
chemicals are secreted and then their
mixture brings out a very combustible
result
number three the greater crate dragon
from the Mandalorian series the greater
Great Dragon was a big species of Great
Dragon predatory reptiles from Tatooine
a planet in the wall of Star Wars
greater crate Dragons sing into the
shifting dunes and also the rocky
underpods swimming beneath the Sands in
Pursuit Of Prey to Ambush and consume in
the Mandalorian a huge specimen of this
species was discovered and it took the
combined effort of basically a small
army and a killerton of explosives just
to bring it down
number two the buraki from D was the
baraki is an evil Emoji who aspires to
be a Celestial Dragon so that he could
destroy Earth and Heaven and rebuild
them in his own image but before being a
dragon the baraki manifests as a giant
serpent the buraki possesses virtually
unbreakable skin massive strength
amazing velocity or agility and can
miraculously identify the girl with a
Celestial power no matter where or how
far she is he is also learned in Black
Magic which merely hints at his ability
to create dark clouds surrounding a U.S
Bank Tower in Korea and mutate his
followers and number one the war bats
from Godzilla vs gong wombats are
underground or Subterranean apex
predators that live in the hollow
Earth's jungles they are very aggressive
and like contemporary constricted snakes
may use their Serpentine form to call
around their victim and constrict them
to death war bats are gigantic reptiles
Serpentine animals with gray skin and
two very Crimson membrane wings that run
along the top half of its body spotted
by strong spines that are extensions of
the rib cage they have the ability to
fly and are one of the longest Titans in
the monster verse and those are the top
10 Serpentine monsters from movies live
action movies so I hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit the like
button for support and subscribe but
most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam